hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i'm going to explain how
property investing has completely
changed over the last few years and
right now how most of the sophisticated
investors are using something called
bridge to let this is a product that
many lenders are doing but for some
reason people aren't talking about it
because all the wealthy people that are
doing it are just quietly doing it
making loads of money getting on with it
but let me tell you something by
toulette
is kind of dead now
so if you're wanting to just buy a house
and rent it out that's kind of dead but
then
buy refurbished refinance
is
quite risky if you because you can buy a
house
and then refurbish it and then try and
refinance it but it can get down valued
or maybe you can't refinance it because
the lender doesn't let you you don't
know your criteria which is why the
sophisticated investors are using a
bridge and then once they've bridged it
and they've purchased it they're then
switching it over to a buy to let with
the same lender
this changes everything let me explain
what i'm talking about so let's say you
buy a house at the moment for
200 000 pounds
okay if this is just a norm if this is a
buy to let
buy to let you're gonna have to put in a
25 deposit now a 25 deposit is going to
be 50 000 pounds so to get a buy to let
on a 200 000 pound house you need 50
grand however you don't just need 50
grand you also need stamp duty the stamp
duty is probably going to set you back
around about seven grand
so that's 57 grand and what are you then
going to do well you're going to rent it
out let's say you rent it out for a
thousand pounds a month
that's the rent but then we know that
with your mortgage payments and with
your management fees you're probably
going to be left with half of that as
your profit so if you want to make 500
pounds a month
you're gonna need to
put down about 57 maybe 60 grand all in
to make 500 pounds that's cool how many
times are you going to do that in order
to replace the average salary well if
the average salary is just to say 2 000
pounds a month
you're gonna need to do that four times
which is going to mean you're going to
need approximately 60 times 4 which is
240
000 pounds so if you've got two hundred
and forty thousand pounds knocking about
in the bank you could go ahead buy four
properties make two thousand pounds a
month and then you've got the capital
appreciation of the properties as well
and you could then potentially retire
depending on whether you could live on 2
000 a month now what's the big problem
of this the problem with this is that
most people don't have 240 000 pounds
knocking about and you can't even use
borrowed funds because if you let's say
you borrow 240 grand from the bank or
from a friend you're not going to be
able to use that as the deposit because
the mortgage companies are going to say
sorry this needs to be your savings we
can't allow this so that strategy
is kind of hard now hard hard hard so
what's the other solution well the other
solution is instead of buying a property
for 200 000 pounds
and everyone's just offering higher and
higher and the prices are going up and
up and up and up and you're getting
gazumped by numpties first-time buyers
that are just getting married and
they're offering 220 and you're like oh
my goodness instead of that
you're gonna find properties that are
run down
ugly houses that are
unmortgageable
these properties that are unmortgageable
they need to be bought with cash
and because they need to be bought with
cash you can buy them cheap you can buy
them at a discount so you're gonna find
a rundown ugly property and you're gonna
buy it maybe from an auction and you're
gonna buy it for a hundred thousand
pounds how do you find a house for a
hundred thousand pounds
find one that's got structural problems
find one that's got no hot water now for
a start your stamp duty
if you're doing this
if the property is unhabitable your
stamp duty is going to be
zero
so straight away you're saving on tax
you're gonna buy for a hundred thousand
pounds then you're gonna push the value
up by doing a big refurb let's say the
refurb is fifty thousand pounds
and now the value is two hundred
then you're gonna refinance the property
and you're gonna borrow
75
of the new value which is how much 150
000 pounds so you're gonna re
your 150 000 pounds cash again and again
and again now the problem with that is
if you've got 150 grand knocking about
then you could buy a house like this
refurb it refinance it again again again
again again again again but
maybe
you haven't got 150 grand cash so what
are you going to do you're going to do
something called this there's a new
product that lenders are doing it's
called bridge to
let
what does that mean that means that if
you find these types of ugly rundown
houses that are
nasty
you're going to buy them
let's save for 100 grand and pay no
stamp duty but you're going to buy it on
a bridging loan
so you're going to borrow not a hundred
grand maybe 70 grand
on a bridge
and then that refurb that 50 grand
refurb you're also going to borrow
the bridge you're going to you're going
to borrow the refurb money on a bridge
so you're only going to need to put in
now probably about 30 grand let's say of
your own money
but because it's a bridging loan
they don't care where that 30 grand
comes from that can be a bank loan that
can be on a freaking credit card that
can be from your mama it can be from
joan next door it doesn't matter so for
30 grand
you can get a bridge
buy a hundred grand house spend 50 grand
on it and now the value is 200 000
pounds obviously it needs to be the
right kind of deal
and then the same company
that gave you the bridge
is then gonna let you refinance the same
company you might say what happens if it
doesn't value up at 200
well this company that gives you a
bridge to let
is going to tell you what the end value
is going to be so they're going to say
right you're buying the house for 100
you need to spend 50 on it assuming that
the condition is x y and z it's good
condition we will then give you a 75
loan against the new value so we'll give
you we'll give you 70 grand now plus 50.
we'll give you 120 grand now for
everything you put 30 grand in and then
at the end
we'll then give you 150 grand
on a buy to let mortgage which is much
cheaper you'll pay about three percent
interest and then you can use that loan
to pay off
that loan which means you're being left
with a free
freaking
house and that
is bridge to let so there are companies
that are providing a bridge to that at
the moment and i'm going to put in the
description i'm going to list some of
the mortgage lenders that are providing
this service if you'd like to actually
do this and you've got questions feel
free to hit me up on instagram and i'll
do my best to help you if you want to
come and spend a day with me at the
property millionaire intensive where
we're going to be finding deals
like this in person then you can do that
for free i'm going to be running a free
training day i'm also going to put a
link below to the property millionaire
intensive and if you found this video
helpful share it around with your
friends and family let's make this go
viral let's change the way that people
think about property investment and
finance see you next time
[Music]
you